as live music also returning to the
fremont street experience on the first
of june guests will be able to enjoy the
entertainment nightly
at all three stages and that is where
sally jeremiah joined
us live she actually spoke to musicians
and sally you say they're just counting
down the days
ryan as we have been reporting las vegas
entertainment
the majority of them not being able to
work for over
a year a tough time for many financially
and emotionally so this is a major
milestone
for them to get back on stage i spoke to
several musicians today
reflecting on the most challenging
months of their careers and they can't
help but look forward to what's to come
many had lost contracts during the
pandemic but instead of dwelling on the
past
they look for ways to reinvent
themselves rick arroyo and michelle
johnson tell me they are ready to return
to the stage
it's exciting because a lot of people
and musicians
have been cooped up and it's like okay
we need to get out i am nervous i
you know a lot of performers will tell
you they don't have stage fright they
don't get nervous
i do some musicians tell me thanks to
performing we assume they were able to
do some work
but are ready for human interaction this
is interesting too some performers are
creating new shows reflecting
on the many challenges they themselves
had to face
through the pandemic for now reporting
live near fairmont street sally
jaramillo 8 news now